president here says if he wins
pennsylvania this was at a rally last
night
he's going to win the whole thing the
whole shebang first of all is that true
in your view and second of all what's
different now two weeks before 2020
compared to 2016
well pennsylvania is very central to his
win strategy
he's got to hold that state the problem
for trump is that
there are no places where he can be
proactive right now
he's got to defend everything and the
problem with that is that he can't go
after states like
minnesota colorado virginia those states
where
maybe republicans were looking to gain
so i think the president has to hold
those states
and i also think what we're going to see
here is the president try to run the
same strategy that he did four years ago
which is really focused on the upper
midwest and really focused on turning
out
rural voters not sure if it's going to
work but i think that's obviously the
playbook the president is going to run
again
well joel let's talk about being not
sure if it's going to work you know
people forget that the majority of
voters across the industrial midwest in
places like michigan
ohio where we are now in pennsylvania
are actually
white non-college educated voters in
other words working class voters
has the president done enough to connect
with those voters or put another way has
he done enough to motivate
more urban voters to come out and vote
against him how is that math going to
work for the president this time around
i think the president certainly has a
cultural connection to those voters
and i think that he's counting on that
working out for him as a turnout
strategy
but i think what the president also
misses is that this is flipped on him in
terms of
those types of populations that
traditionally support him seniors
white voters the margins are a lot
closer to joe biden in fact in some
cases
biden is winning with those voters so
whereas the president was dominating
hillary clinton
four years ago in some of those
categories the the flip is completely
uh this the script is completely flipped
rather this time around
all right joel i'm told we have leslie
back leslie if you can hear me i'm to go
to you here uh you know i do
the president thank you i'm glad welcome
to live tv america uh you know
the president of 2016 for for all the
the general chaos and
the newness of his campaign he had a
disciplined message down the closing
stretch
this time some are saying he doesn't
he's attacking leslie stahl he's
attacking
anthony fauci how do you think what
could be a lack of discipline in his
messaging
may impact the vote this year
what's interesting about that if you
listen to him last night and the package
right before here when you're talking
about the forgotten man it
a lot of that galvanized or in many
cases activated
this blue collar nation and and that
idea was that there's so many voters and
they said it themselves who weren't
connected to republicans
or democrats but heard the message of
this outsider this unorthodox approach
and they wanted to get on the bandwagon
they're still with the president he's
activating it again right now
in the sense of talking about his
accomplishments and kind of sticking to
to that line but i would tell you tony
the debate coming up and how well the
president can stick to that message and
going back to
energizing especially uh those
particular states
is really going to determine whether he
can close that gap coming to election
day
yeah leslie one of the more fascinating
dynamics of this election cycle
is that the president turns out to be a
great motivator but for both sides so
his supporters want to vote for him
and joe biden's supporters want to vote
against president trump
talk to me about that dynamic and who it
benefits
you know in in this case so 2016 was
just kind of happenstance that the
president was able to do that you were
talking about what 78
000 votes out of 137 million that really
made the decision up in those rust belt
states
what now is a much it's a much more
articulated machine
not only in data contact your cell phone
engagement
all of those tools that both campaigns
are using they're using with these
messages so the air war
the tactical war uh in terms of campaign
tactics
is it may turn out to be extremely
effective
for the president a lot of these are
these floating voters in here in europe
they call them floating voters people
that are on the roll
only turn out once or twice to vote yeah
once or twice in their lifetime they may
vote that's what the president's looking
for
is to really make a strategy out of
pulling them into 2020.
yeah turnout is always what is
consequential and ultimately decisive
could be messy but that's what matters
joel